what's your step-by-step guide to
producing a short film here in la
on a short film um
first page count that's everyone always
like thinks like what kind of short film
you want to make
do something that's um doable or
unattainable for you like
location wise knowing like something
that you get for like cheap or free
don't have a lot of locations don't have
a lot of actors
um don't work with like certain elements
like
i always say working indoors because
less elements
like rain animal people crowd work like
crowds and stuff like that
um i always tell like if you're gonna do
your first
short or a second short always keep it
between like five to ten pages
because it's short quick do your three
act structure um just
in your range right like one or two
locations two to three characters
something like that um besides that
la it's really hard to shoot short films
um
i'm gonna use the example of my my short
film night night
we actually had a shoot outside of l.a
county because it was a non-union
project
we had teamsters try to prevent us
shooting into county because it wasn't
union
and i don't know how they found out
which i think was part of sag
because we wouldn't use sag actors
because a lot of my projects i use
sag like i do sac projects like all my
sketch comedy stuff everything's sag
so i have like i'm in a signatory for
sag
as a producer and they i guess they
caught wind of it and stuff
and they're like we need to do union so
we shot it out in pomona
so it's like right outside the county
line so you couldn't be like oh you
can't do this so we're like
but always so it's gonna be really hard
with that um sorry what were the
teamsters doing like
they would just like try to like find
where we are and prevent us from like
shooting
like they would like go to our places
like it was weird
they really they were trying to prevent
us from like there was no strikes like
like boycott but like they sit down we
would get like emails like
especially on craigslist like they were
like what was it like
one of my producers um was putting ad on
craigslist which i would never use
craigslist again
i was looking for like a pa or something
and um
and what would we pay all everyone
anyways but uh
people were just like oh you you need to
be union and
like you get weird emails i'm sitting
there i was like okay
and once again they're not like real
people that it's under anonymous names
again and i always do that i'm like
like okay it's like oh you're what's
wrong with the business
not using i'm like not
using union i'm like right it's because
you pay union dues and you haven't
gotten a job six months and you're
flipping burgers i'm like
like a lot of people i just sit there
and i look at them like
okay but yeah we get like weird things
even like one of my friends uh
shane ryan he had issues like that too
when he gets like every time when you
play like for crew and stuff you always
have that
one weirdo who always like emails you
like oh
you're what's wrong with the business
leave l.a
and like they were like i'm like wow
okay that's extreme
[Laughter]
so yeah it's like we still have to deal
with people like that you haven't
arrived until you get those emails so
maybe it's
amazing i'm like sitting there like with
comedy and stuff like oh we hate you i'm
like
i don't know you so it's like but yeah
it's like
that was one of the things i tell
students too is like just don't
shoot where you need like if you have an
apartment where you have access to your
own apartment
shoot something simple like keep working
like that
also don't post it on youtube don't do
your first few films on youtube i
i don't get why they do that i i'm like
because all your stuff is going to look
like crap at first when you're first
starting out
it's going to look like crap shoot i do
stuff now i look and i'm like
why did i use that lens like why did i
why is that light that way
like oh you suck but it doesn't matter
it's like you're always gonna like the
first few films
it's gonna be garbage and they're always
like but i wanna show people my progress
i'm like yeah but so the studio
executive is gonna
google your name and see your crap and
like yeah i don't know
so i'm like people don't think that
business-wise we're just like oh i'm
trying to get fans and like
no like they look at it and they're like
this is garbage and then their boss will
see it and what their boss
who doesn't have the time limit you have
to see this the progression say that
executive saw your progression
his boss is not going to waste his time
and see he's going to see that one video
clip and be like
nope bye-bye so like a lot of people
i'm like so i tell people don't do that
um
but that's also another pro for film
school too it's like you're in a
safer group of people safe space
i know that's that word like but uh
so you could like test out your
knowledge and like
play around with style and technique but
it's like
don't just go out like oh this is great
it's like yeah but you did your whole
short it's a master shot there's no
coverage there's no cut away i'm like
what are you doing i'm like so people
show that and that's always what kills
me
and then also i have a vision of what
you're doing like i don't do storyboards
i do um
shot lists i always do shot lists like i
just don't like storyboards because like
because not gonna look anything what i
envision
someone could when go to location and
everything's gonna change there's like
someone told me like there's
three processes when you're having your
hair when you write it and then you
shoot it and like it's just
totally different like my my stuff
always
looks a lot different than when i
originally shoot i'm like oh it's like
okay
because i like i'm savage when it comes
to my movies like where i shoot
everything
and i'm like okay i want this cut this
cut i don't like that shot and my
editor's like
okay like they i give them what they
want to do but like i know like okay
like if they need to cut something cut
it if it doesn't work cut it a lot of
people can't be precious with their
footage where they're like
but it's an art piece and i'm like no
it's like
does it work well your fans get it
you're telling a story that's what i
look at it
why don't you like the word audience i
don't know i feel like um
audience is a very vague word it's like
once again you're labeling
like who's in your audience fans like
what like it's like who's your audience
like oh my audience
like okay who is it is it women
male are they kids are teenagers are
they adults
so it's just like they want to make it
generalize
you like in this business don't
generalize you want to be
that's the whole mainstream thing where
people always get mad about like oh
and that's why a lot of shows i don't
think succeed or film succeed because
they don't
have a point of view because they're
trying to make everyone happy
it's like no you're going to do
something then no one's going to be
happy because
everything is is too too broad so
when you have to make it smaller smaller
and smaller yeah it might
limit your audience or lack of i should
say audience again
your fan base but at least you know you
have a point of view
where that's how i look at it well the
thing is though
the audience doesn't always make up fans
it can be true
like trolls haters oh yeah exactly and
that's the thing again it's just like
that's not an audience again like
because audience i feel like is a fickle
word it's just like an audience could be
like
that like once again it's like oh i'm a
fan oh i hate your work
because you see that with like comic
book movies like where you saw that
happen to captain marvel they're like
what a female superhero oh my god dude
like he's sitting here like i was like
ugh like i'm like okay nerds
nerds but uh it's like
people always like once again people
want to look at something to get
offended
and like i've always had better luck
with people of a certain niche like i
have a target where i'm like okay this
is the kind of stuff i want to do
and i'll put it out to that audience or
that base that fan base i should say
face is a good word i think um and then
eventually people will come if they like
it if it's good
like when i was younger i was like i
want to win awards and be critically
acclaimed
now i'm to the point where i was like i
just want to create entertain
and inspire that's all i want to do like
if i could do that
and make a little bit of money and not
like work like a day job
i did my job i did i could die happy
i could die happy but everyone's like oh
this and that i'm like no
it's like just find something and narrow
it down
you